INTERVIEWER: We've all
heard the old cliche
that pictures capture
an exact moment in time.
But that is what they do.
The bouquet floating in the air,
the happy bride, the excited
tourists.
This odd mix of
people and emotions
only existed this one
time for this one moment,
and the photograph was
able to capture it all.
The person responsible for
catching this particular split
second was this guy.
JOSE MANUEL RIOS: Hi, my
name is Jose Manuel Rios.
I am a closed captioning
technician for hearing
impaired, video editor,
and amateur photographer
based in Seville, Spain.
This picture was
taken August, 2011.
It was a warm evening
with fantastic weather.
That summer, I was traveling
through Italy with my partner,
and I was taking my camera
with me all the time.
INTERVIEWER: The photo was
taken in the Piazza del Duomo.
The Piazza is the
heart of Florence,
as well as its historic center
full of beautiful architecture
and buildings dating
back almost 1,000 years.
So it's no wonder that Jose
was drawn here with camera
in hand ready for anything.
JOSE MANUEL RIOS: That evening
when I arrived to the Piazza,
the bride was there with
a wedding photographer.
But everybody there
was looking at her.
And many, many people, mostly
tourists, were gathering around
and the place was full.
Everybody wanted to
catch the bouquet.
So I prepare my camera,
and fortunately I
got the picture of
this exact moment.
Everybody was so happy, and
you can feel it in the picture.
I was just lucky to be in the
right place at the right time.
INTERVIEWER: And that is how
memories like this happen,
intentionally or otherwise.
At least that's what
happened to Jose, this crowd,
and oh yeah, this little girl.
JOSE MANUEL RIOS:
I don't know how,
but this little young
girl grabbed the bouquet.
It was so fast that I
didn't see it coming.
I was just taking pictures
and suddenly this kid had it.
INTERVIEWER: It was
a pretty great moment
for everyone, the girl, the
bride, the crowd, and Jose.
JOSE MANUEL RIOS: For me, as a
photographer, this was so cool.
I could capture this unique
moment with my camera.
And I'm sure all that people
will always remember this.
I'm glad I could take
part of this moment.
INTERVIEWER: At
"This Happened Here"
we're always
looking for new ways
to tell stories through photos.
If you'd like to be
featured on our show,
send us a link to
your photography
website below in the comments.
And don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.